I can speak now to Mary bowsted who's
joint general secretary at the National
Education Union so a very good afternoon
to you
um so this is big news obviously
affecting lots of different sectors but
tell us how the pay deal that's been
offered affects you what exactly has
been offered to teachers and why have
you been minded to accept it
so the pay deal is the review body
recommendation of six and a half percent
uh pay rise for teachers and leaders and
a six and a half percent on any
allowances that they might have for
extra responsibilities it's the biggest
pay award that the independent review
body has ever made and importantly we've
secured guarantees on how it will be
funded which means that Frontline
Support Services in schools will not be
affected
well yes talk me through that funding
because we have heard from the
government they're not going to borrow
anymore and they're not going to put
taxes up and they've talked about
re-prioritizing within departments and
the fear is that to fund these pay Rises
they may have to be cut somewhere within
that department so you're saying you're
getting extra money to make sure that
schools won't lose out
yes well the the we've been we've
received guarantees that the funding
will not come from the school's building
program because school buildings are in
a terrible state it won't come from
spending on special educational needs uh
and the tea won't come from uh post 16
funding or from attained nurseries so
we've received written uh guarantees
that the funding will not affect
Frontline services in schools
well you know the the vast majority of
schools will find the pay award
affordable because head teachers will
have budgeted for a three and a half
percent pay rise because that's what
they were advised to do that's what they
government said to the sdrb at the pay
review body was affordable uh from the
government point of view so there's an
extra three percent which the government
will fund from under spends in the
department now it's not up to us where
the government finds money from that's a
matter for government what we've
obtained is guarantees that it will not
affect Frontline services in schools or
in colleges
and you and the other union leaders have
said that you'll put this offer now to
your members but you're recommending
they accept it do you think that they
will given that although as you say this
is the biggest rise that has been
offered before of six and a half percent
it's still well below inflation which is
8.7 percent
um well that will be up to the members
but we will say to the members very
clearly that this is an offer that we
think they should
bank they should accept this offer
because it is the biggest rise that uh
they've had in years uh we have that by
their action my members have taken eight
days of strike action those days of
strike action have moved to the
government from an initial offer of
three and a half percent to six and a
half percent that is a significant move
now yes it is still below inflation uh
but we will you know we will continue to
campaign
for teachers to gradually restore their
pay to the levels it was in 2010. we
always knew that it was going to be a
very tall order to get there in one year
what we're saying is this is a good
start
so you wouldn't rule out strike action
in future
well so you'd never do that strike
actually future but what we have said is
uh if members accept this deal and they
will have a vote on it then the dispute
we have currently with the government on
pay is over for this year and uh for
next uh for September's pay awards that
is the end of this dispute yes I'm not
going to rule out strike action ever
again I mean I'm sure that's not what
you meant by the question
no I meant I meant in a year's time
perhaps so so if if
you you were resolved along with other
education unions to accept this offer
but what do you make of the Prime
Minister sending out a message to other
unions saying there'll be no more talks
on pay and no amount of strikes will
change that decision did do you respect
that he he says that's that a reasonable
position from your point of view well no
I don't think it's ever a reasonable
position not to have further talks with
unions who it's very hard to take strike
action in this country the the
thresholds uh the rules around strikas
are such that the international labor
organization says that it's you know the
government's not acting according to
International Labor uh uh regulations so
no I wouldn't say never having any more
negotiations is a good move but I can't
talk for the Prime Minister he's got to
make his own announcements I always
think you should negotiate with unions
uh we have had negotiations with the
government they have agreed to honor the
independent pay review body and we have
agreed to put that offer to members and
say to them this is the best offer
you're going to get through negotiation
and give us an idea of what it's been
like for teachers
carrying out this strike action as you
say eight days of it
well it's been grueling it's been
remarkable that teachers have stayed the
course that the strikes were straight
strong and that they have stayed
determined it has been very hard for
them but this is a deal which
gives them the best
um uh the best award on pay that they've
had in nearly over uh two decades it
gives them uh you know a a better place
on which to stand in terms of the real
value of their pay although as you say
it is still below inflation and it means
that and and crucially the funding for
this pay award is not coming out of
Frontline services for schools all in
all we are recommending that to our
members as the best deal that they can
get through negotiation of course it's
up to them whether they accept or reject
that deal okay well Mary bastard thank
you so much for joining us and giving
your a very Swift reaction to this news
joint general secretary at the National
Education Union thanks very much indeed